hot off the heels of the battle for the
stepstones hbo has released a promo
video for episode 4. if you're new here
be warned this is a major spoiler video
where i take a deep dive into the book
and trailers and if you haven't seen the
trailer yet i've left a link to it in
the description but please come back i
am so very lonely check out this bird's
eye view of what i believe to be one of
the courtyards in the red keep look how
the tiling matches the female servants
here the ones with the bonnets look a
lot like those nurse maids we saw in
episode 3. all of them carry lanterns
suggesting they're on the lookout for
someone and as the trailer will suggest
that someone is rhaenyra rhaenyra reads
an inscription from the cat's paw dagger
that seems to be only visible when put
under fire the high valyrian message
reads from my blood come the prince that
was promised and here's where things get
a little complicated this could be a
reference to the prophecy of the azor
ahai which foretold the coming of a hero
to deliver the world from darkness
according to melisandre this prophecy is
5 000 years old but the show has
introduced king aegon's prophecy which
he named a song of fire and ice and
that's only about a hundred years old it
foretold of a targaryen ruler on the
throne who would lead the fight against
the darkness it's interesting that the
wording here refers to a he a prince
which you think would rule out arya who
would end up killing the night king or
daenerys who would end up on the throne
as this prophesized figure it just so
happens that the word prince in high
valerian is gender-neutral so it could
refer to a male or female i like to
think that this prophesized person is
jon snow however it'll be interesting to
see how the show tackles both book canon
and show canon a particular note is the
cat's pod dagger the same weapon that
arya will use to kill the night king
hundreds of years later in season 7 we
see samwell tarly reading a book about
this dagger that states when aegon the
conqueror forged his seven kingdoms he
and his descendants would often decorate
their blades with dragonglass feeling a
kinship with the stone its blade is made
of valyrian steel and hilt that of
dragonglass the only two substances
known to kill white walkers in the
season trailers we've seen allison to
wield this blade and attack rhaenyra
with it it's a bit difficult to tell
what happens in the scene but my
prediction is she takes it off king
viserys who at this point will be much
more sick and attempts to stab the
princess this may be because one of
ranira's children cut out the eye of one
of hers ranira seems to be alongside her
father here who is showing her this
inscription further highlighting the
blade's importance notice at this point
rhaenyra is not wearing that valerian
steel necklace she received from her
uncle in episode 1 yet later in the
trailer she is in the season to come
trailer we get this added voiceover of
the king in this scene stating that the
quote burden of this knowledge is larger
than the throne the hand of the king
otto hightower skulks off to the side of
the great hall i'm wondering if this is
when prince damon returns from the
stepstones we'll see someone who could
be otto in this wide shot plus the
servant with the pillow looks to be the
same one who gives viserys his crown
during this tense confrontation take
note of prince damon here either in the
red keep or some brothel his hair
notably shorter than when we saw him at
the stepstones we'll find out that this
episode takes place roughly one year
after the events of episode 3. what i
want you to pay attention to is his
white shirt in the season ahead trailer
we see the king hold a dagger to his
brother telling him he's no conqueror
he's a plague these two seem to be alone
here in the great hall and the king
events his frustration now that his
brother must be seen as a hero even
though he went against his brother's
wishes there's not much we can pick out
here other than alison is no longer
pregnant in the year that passed she
would have given birth to her second of
four children helena past the skull of
valerian you can make out a figure
walking in the background the season
ahead trailer has a better shot of this
person and will later see a similarly
clothed rhaenyra running through the
streets with a shot of a drunk in the
background combine this with these
servants looking for someone it appears
rhaenyra has slipped out of the red keep
not wanting to be noticed perhaps it has
something to do with her uncle we'll see
him clad in a black cloak he too looks
as though he does not want to be
discovered the king puts on his crown
awaiting their rival of damon who also
wears a crown that of the stepstones in
the book corliss named him the king of
the narrow sea that patch of water
separating westeros from essos these
would be seas belonging to king viserys
so each men flaunting their crowns is
nothing but a glorified dick-swinging
contest i'm really curious why rhaenyra
is wearing her uncle's necklace here the
last we saw these two interact it could
have led to her death perhaps they've
made up or maybe rhaenyra just wants to
piss off her father returning to the
great hall is daemon holding
kragustrahar's hammer the same one the
crab feeder used to nail his victims to
driftwood the kingsguard have their
swords drawn and we even see sir harold
westerling with his blade against the
prince's chest if the show is to follow
the book this scene will end with daemon
bending the knee before the king what
you can't see unless you have the closed
captions on is a street performer asking
who will be heir the brother daughter or
prince aegon judging by these oddly
dressed figures and this magic performer
i wonder if some sort of street festival
is happening in town this magic dude is
also interesting because we just don't
know if he's using some kind of
pyrotechnic or if he's an actual magic
user to me he looks like some lowly
street performer but who knows the king
tells reinirro that her courtship is at
an end i guess she's had a year to look
for someone to marry after her father
told her in episode 3 she could have
anyone of her choosing it appears one of
these suitors could be a baratheon with
the baratheon emblem etched on the wall
here my guess is this is storm's end and
the manta ray near his right looks like
it may be the baratheon knight bormand
who we saw at the tournament in episode
1. perhaps one of the reasons rhaenyra
has not chosen a husband is that she's
secretly in love with her knight sir
kristen cole in the book it says quote
though many lords and nights sought her
favor the princess had eyes only for sir
kristen cole the young champion of the
kingsguard and her constant companion
things between the king and princess
have heated up and he expresses that she
is his political headache we get this
lovely shot is it king's landing or
somewhere else and here we have queen
allison holding her baby princess helena
you can see this takes place at king's
landing with the dragonpit visible in
the background and now for the main
drama of the episode otto approaches the
king with some salacious rumors but
knowing otto just how true these rumors
are we can't be sure the man is always
doing things to further house hightower
so it would make sense he may create
rumors to celebrate near his reputation
in order to get aegon named as air but
something does seem to happen here in
the shadows a hand on top of another in
an alleyway could this be the cloaked
daemon and rhaenyra the hand does have a
ring on it and daemon does wear a ring
on that finger rhaenyra also slipped out
during the night but we just can't tell
the book portrays two differing events
that could be these rumors otto refers
to one is from septon eustis who writes
that sir eric cargill of the kingsguard
caught damon and the princess in a bed
together with rhaenyra pleading to her
father that she was in love with her
uncle and that they should leave
together to marry even though damon
already has a wife the show however
seems to be more aligned with a man by
the name of mushroom's account rhaenyra
was in love with sir kristen and damon
upon sensing this told his niece that he
could make sir kristen quote see her as
a woman rinira would disguise herself as
a pageboy and meet her uncle at the
brothels on the street of silk where she
could observe the art of lovemaking she
would however save her innocence for sir
kristen as a gift but upon approaching
him and telling him of her love and all
that she had learned he is horrified and
spurns her remember also that members of
the kingsguard take a vow of celibacy
i'm really interested to see how the
writers take the source material and
which way they twist it for the purposes
of the show the king asks who is
responsible for this gossip as he will
take out their eyes if it's auto that's
gotta be one scary threat a quick shot
of the king approaching damon in the
great hall holding his valyrian
longsword blackfyre alison says that
it's not in rainier's nature to be
deceitful although she can't say the
same for damon so it does seem these
rumors are about rhaenyra and daemon
here we see the princess on a targaryen
ship alongside sir kristen i'm really
curious when in the episode this takes
place whether it's before or after those
vile rumors because the ship is followed
by damon's dragon karaxis rhaenyra
doesn't seem to be too concerned here i
think she knows that her uncle won't
harm her but now i turn it over to you
what are these vile rumors about and
just what will go down between damon and
rhaenyra if anything i want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone
please be sure to like and subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember it's a crispin
wasn't it